is it true that you showed the Star Wars
movie to a guy who was dying
Daniel Fleetwood who was sadly
terminally ill and had reached out in
many ways Twitter but also personally to
see this movie and we've been very lucky
to get to show the film to a handful of
people who have been in an unfortunate
situation did you feel manipulated by
that you know there were some people who
will even use that to get to see a movie
yes and there they're full of [ __ ] these
are not people who are looking to screw
us you had them vetted yes they do this
and he's P passed away I think far right
I was gonna say that guy owned up and
died did you did you yeah he put his
money where his mom owned up yeah I I've
spoken to the people who have seen the
film both before and after and it's been
very sobering and and an honor to get to
do it I mean the fact that these people
care enough about this world that George
Lucas created to to want to see this
movie JJ did any of the dying people
come to you and say thank you for
showing us me but boy oh boy this was a
huge disappointment I know why they
bothered with this I mean I only have a
few days left to live so sorry
[ __ ] me over I've anyone said they had
not gotten that reaction you did not